Wie hofft Wladimir Putin, den internationalen
Sanktionen standhalten zu können?
Hat der russische Präsident irgendwelche
Pläne, um den Wirtschaftskrieg zu gewinnen?
Was genau sind Russlands Mittel, um diesen
Kampf zu führen?
Warum stürzte der Rubel nach der Invasion
ab, gewann aber darauf hin wieder an Wert
und ist nun sogar teurer als vor dem Krieg?
Bedeutet dies, dass der Kreml den Wirtschaftskrieg
gegen den Westen gewinnt?
Nun, lebe VisualPolitik-Zuschauer, in diesem
Video werden wir all diese Fragen beantworten.
Also...
lasst uns doch gleich anfangen!
Der Krieg in der Ukraine, eine grausame und
rücksichtslose Invasion, erweist sich nicht
nur auf dem Schlachtfeld als großer Alptraum,
sondern hat auch weitaus größere wirtschaftliche
Auswirkungen als erwartet.
Das gilt für die ganze Welt, insbesondere
jedoch für die russische Wirtschaft.
Niemand in Moskau hat sich vorgestellt, dass
es 2022 so schlecht laufen würde.
Was als Spezialeinsatz angekündigt wurde,
hat sich zu einem intensiven Zermürbungskrieg
entwickelt, der enorme Kosten in Form von
Menschenleben, Ausrüstung und Ressourcen
aller Art verursacht.
Schätzungen zu folge kostet allein die Kriegsführung
Russland zwischen einer halben und einer Milliarde
Dollar pro Tag.
Und in diesen Kosten sind die Wirtschaftssanktionen
noch nicht eingerechnet, jene internationale
Reaktion von einem Kaliber, dass sie jeden
Notfallplan des Kremls übertroffen hat.
Innerhalb weniger Wochen nach der Invasion
wurde Russland zu einer Art Paria, zu einem
weitgehend isolierten Land, für dessen Flugzeuge
ein Großteil des weltweiten Luftraums gesperrt
ist und internationale Unternehmen - in Angst
und Schrecken versetzt – aus dem flohen,
da es weitgehend aus dem internationalen Finanzsystem
ausgeschlossen und mit einer Vielzahl von
Handelsbeschränkungen belegt wurde.
Allein in Moskau sind jetzt Zehntausende von
Arbeitsplätzen durch den Wegzug multinationaler
Unternehmen gefährdet, was sogar der kremltreue
Bürgermeister der russischen Hauptstadt selbst
bestätigt.
("Unseren Schätzungen zufolge sind etwa 200.000
Menschen vom Verlust ihres Arbeitsplatzes
bedroht."
Sergej Sobjanin, Bürgermeister Moskaus)
Nun ja, immerhin ist der Arbeitsplatzverlust
nicht so schlimm wie als Konnenfutter an der
Front verheizt zu werden.
Diese "Ehre" bleibt den armen Schluckern aus
entlegeneren Regionen vorbehalten, die Moskauer
dürfen weiter in ihrer Bubble am Leben bleiben.
Sie werden jedoch Abstriche machen müssen,
denn die Aussichten für die russische Wirtschaft
düster geworden.
Da die Sanktionen die Importe gedrosselt haben,
viele russische Unternehmen ihre Geschäftstätigkeit
aufgrund von Lieferengpässen einschränken
müssen, Hunderte westlicher Unternehmen das
Land verlassen und Tausende Russen ihren Arbeitsplatz
verlieren, gerät die russische Wirtschaft
ins Stocken.
Um Euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben: Nach
Angaben der russichen Zentralbank selbst wird
das russische BIP bis 2022 um mindestens 8
% sinken, wobei die Prognosen der Europäische
Bank für Wiederaufbau und Entwicklung eher
gen 10 % gehen, die der Weltbank auf über
11 % und des Institute of International Finance
gar auf 15 %.
Wir sprechen hier von der schlimmsten Rezession
in Russland seit Anfang der 1990er Jahre.
Und vergesst nicht, dass wir nur über das
erste Jahr sprechen.
Mittel- und langfristig erwarten viele Analysten,
dass es noch schlimmer kommen wird, viel,viel
schlimmer.
("Die besten Schätzungen, die ich im Moment
sehe, deuten darauf hin, dass die russische
Wirtschaft auf die Hälfte dessen reduziert
wird, was sie vor der Invasion war.
Daleep Singh, stellvertretender nationaler
Sicherheitsberater der USA)
("Es wird weniger Investitionen geben, weniger
internationalen Handel, weniger Integration
Russlands in globale Wertschöpfungsketten,
und dies wird in Kombination mit dem Exodus
von Fachkräften, langfristig ein geringeres
Produktivitätswachstum nach sich ziehen."
Beata Javorcik, Chefvolkswirtin bei der Europäischen
Bank für Wideraufbau und Entwicklung)
Aber lasst uns zu den Fragen zurückkehren,
die wir am Anfang gestellt haben:
Wie hofft Wladimir Putin, den internationalen
Sanktionen zu widerstehen?
Was ist sein Plan?
Um das zu ergründen, müssen wir zunächst
einmal genau wissen, wie es Russland derzeit
geht und was eigentlich Putins gesamte Ära
aus ökonomischer Sicht am besten charakteriert.
Also: aufgepasst!
(EIN NEUER ZAR FÜR EIN REICH IM NIEDERGANG)
Bereits in mehreren Videos hier auf VisualPolitik
haben wir dokumentiert, dass der Fall der
Sowjetunion und der Übergang zur Marktwirtschaft
alles andere als ein Zuckerschlecken war.
Krasse Misswirtschaft, zügellose Korruption,
marode Staatsfinanzen bis hin zum Staatsbankrott
und schließlich eine gigantische Finanzkrise
machten die 1990er Jahre zu einem dramatischen
Jahrzehnt für Russland.
Zwischen 1990 und 1998 ist das reale Pro-Kopf-BIP
der Russen zum Beispiel um mehr als 40 % gesunken
- und das gar von einem Ausgangsniveau, das
auch nicht besonders beeindruckend wat.
Nun, aus diesem ganzen Debakel ist Wladimir
Putin hervorgegangen.
Er wurde im Jahr 2000 Präsident und versprach,
einen umfassenden Reformprozess einzuleiten,
um das Land zu modernisieren.
Und er begann mit der Wirtschaft.
Kurz nach seinem Amtsantritt brachte Putins
Regierung den sogenannten Gref-Plan auf den
Weg, einen Plan, der Investoren anlocken sollte.
Und wisstt Ihr was?
In gewisser Weise war dieser Plan ein Erfolg.
Ja, die Korruption blieb auf hohem Niveau,
aber die wirtschaftliche Lage in Russland
hat sich deutlich verbessert.
Die Regierung trieb die Privatisierung und
Deregulierung großer Wirtschaftssektoren
voran, versuchte internationale Investoren
anzuziehen und führte eine pauschale Einkommenssteuer
von 13 % ein.
Eine Pauschalsteuer, mit der Putin in der
internationalen Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft viele
Punkte sammeln konnte.
Doch Putin hatte auch verdammt viel Glück.
Geopolitiscches Glück.
Nur kurz nach seinem Amtsantritt ging schaltete
Chinas Wirtschaftsboom in den endgültigen
Turbo-Modus und die Kriegsabenteuer der Bush/Chaney-Gang
im Nahen Osten verursachten eine gravierende
Instabilität bei der Ölversorgung.
Durch Kombination dieser beiden Entwicklugen
ging der Ölpreis durch die Decke und blieb
dort für viele Jahre.
Allein zwischen 2002 und 2008 stiegen die
Ölpreise fast um das Vierfache - etwas besseres
hätte Putin und seiner Clique damals nicht
passieren können.
Sie konnten einen gigantischen Reibach machen
und: sogar ein paar von ihren hunderten Millarden
an Petrodollars an die russische Bevölkerung
durchtröpfeln lassen.
Nun ja, wenn man bei einem Niveau von 2.000
Dollar Jahreseinkommen pro Kopf anfängt,
kann man auch mit nur einem kleinen Bruchteil
der Ölmillarden für viel Freude beim Volk
Sorgen.
Tatsache ist, dass die Reformen zusammen mit
dem Dauerhoch beim Ölpreis das russische
Pro-Kopf-Einkommen von besagten 2.000 US-Dollar
auf einen Höchststand von immer 16.000 US-Dollar
pro Jahr in den frühen 2010er Jahren ansteigen
ließen.
Was wir nicht vergessen dürfen: die 16.000
Dollar pro Jahr - was ja auch kein großer
Reichtum ist - sind der Durchschnittswert,
in dem auch die Millioneneinkommen der Eliten
enthalten sind, sie entsprechen nicht dem,
was Ivan Normalverbraucher zur Verfügung
stand.
Aber allein der gewaltige relative Anstieg
trieb Putins Popularität innerhalb und auch
außerhalb Russlands in schwindelerregende
Höhen.
Das Problem war jedoch, dass es mit all den
schönen Reformen bald zu Ende ging.
Aufgrund der gigantischen Rohstoffeinnahmen
verfügte die russische Regierung über so
viele Ressourcen, dass sie einfach dacht,
weitere Reformen seinen nicht mehr nötig.
Im Gegenteil: Nach und nach drehte sich die
russische Wirtschaft immer mehr um den Kreml,
während die Korruption weiter in die Höhe
schoss und die neuen Reformpläne, die vorgestellt
wurden, nie in Gang kamen.
Und so kam es, wie es kommen musste: Der Herr
hat's Russland gegeben und er hat's auch wieder
genommen.
Zusammen mit dem Einbruch der Ölpreise im
Jahr 2014 und den Sanktionen nach der Invasion
auf der Krim hat sich das Blatt gewendet.
Seht Euch einfach mal diese Grafik an:
Wenn wir uns den Anteil Russlands am weltweiten
BIP ansehen, hat sich 20 Jahre nach der Machtübernahme
der Kreis wieder geschlossen.
Russland steht wieder am Anfang, heute aber
noch dazu mit einer katastrophalen Demographie
und gewaltigen Sanktionen.
Ja, die Russen sind heute reicher als im Jahr
2000, aber gegenüber dem Rest der Welt hat
sich nichts geändert und im Vergleich zu
anderen Ländern, die damals auch am Boden
lagen, sich jedoch in der Zwischenzeit wirtschaftlich
emanzipieren konnten, ist Russland in krasser
Weise zurückgefallen.
Vergleicht man die Entwicklung z.B. mit der
des einstigen russischen Vasallenstaats Polen,
wird erst das ganze Ausmaß von Putins Versagen
deutlich.
War die russische Volkswirtschaft im Jahr
2014 noch vier mal so groß wie die Polens
– was etwa auch dem Verhältnis der Einwohnerzahlen
entspricht -, so erreichte Polens Wirtschaftsleistung
7 Jahre später bereits 40% der Russlands
und dürfte nun nach dem Kriegseinbruch die
50%-Marke gerissen haben.
Es ist daher – wenn man noch das weitere
Wachtumspotential Polens berücksichtigt - durchaus
realistisch zu erwarten, dass die Größe
der Wirtschaft Russlands bald der Polens entsprechen
oder sogar kleiner sein wird.
Und was noch viel schlimmer ist: Es gibt keinerlei
Zukunftsperspektive.
Nicht nur, weil die russische Bevölkerung
ohne nennenswerte Ersparnisse und Produktivitätspuffer
vergreist und ausstirbt.
Das was von der russischen Wirtschaft übrig
bleibt, wird zunehmend von großen, ineffizienten
und korrupten Konzernen beherrscht, deren
Tätigkeit vor allem von der Gunst der Regierung
abhängt.
Das ist der Grund, warum Russland zum Beispiel
nur Rohstoffe exportiert.
Der einzig nenneswerte Exportsektor, in dem
Russland mit einer gewissen Wertschöpfung
noch mithalten konnte - die Rüstungsindustrie
- dürfte nach der desaströsen "negativen
Werbekampage" in der Ukraine nun auch in der
Versenkung verschwinden.
In diesem ultimativen Test durfte die ganze
Welt durch die katastrophale Performance des
russischen Militärs endgültig Zeuge der
enormen Auswirkungen der Korruption und Misswirtschaft
auf die Qualtiät russischer Rüstungsprodukte
werden.
Aber darüber haben wir schon in unserem letzten
Video gesprochen.
Wie dem auch sei, Tatsache ist, dass mit den
Sanktionen, die nach dem Einmarsch in der
Ukraine gegen Russland verhängt wurden, die
Dinge noch viel, viel schlimmer werden könnten.
Denn selbst wenn jetzt sofort der Krieg in
der Ukraine zu Ende gehen solte, fängt für
Russland der Kampf ums wirtschaftliche Überleben
erst jetzt richtig an.
Und wie Ihr sehen könnt, scheint Russland
nicht gerade in bester Verfassung in diese
entscheidende Schlacht zu gehen.
Die russische Wirtschaft ist von Korruption
durchsetzt, die Unternehmen sind nicht nur
bei der Förderung von Rohstoffen sehr ineffizient
und sowohl der Konsum als auch die Produktion
vor Ort sind stark von internationalen Lieferketten
abhängig.
Was Putin bisher vielleicht am besten gemacht
hat, war, die Ausgaben und die Staatsverschuldung
in Schach zu halten.
Vor allem nach der Invasion der Krim, als
der Kreml nach der ersten Runde der Sanktionen
begriff, dass ein gesunder Staatshaushalt
und viele internationale Reserven notwendig
waren, um den Wirtschaftskrieg zu führen.
Im Jahr 2014 begann die russische Regierung,
einen Notfallplan zu entwickeln, der nun vollständig
umgesetzt werden muss.
Ein Plan, in dem diese Frau eine Schlüsselrolle
spielt: Elvira Nabiullina.
Ja, okay, ich weiß, sie hat nicht das typische
Gesicht eines Cartoon-Bösewichts, aber diese
Frau führt tatsächlich die Gegenoffensive
an, mit der Putin hofft, den Wirtschaftskrieg,
den die Verbündeten gegen Russland angezettelt
haben, zu gewinnen oder zumindest zu widerstehen.
Und wie sie das zu tun gedenkt, sehen wir
uns jetzt genauer an.
(DIE FRAU, DIE DEN RUBEL WIEDER ROLLEN LÄSST)
Den Krieg in der Ukraine gewinnen und einen
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenbruch vermeiden.
Das sind die beiden Ziele, welche die russische
Regierung zu ihren obersten Prioritäten erklärt
hat und Elvira Nabiullina, die Chefin der
russischen Zentralbank, ist eine der Schlüsselfiguren
bei der Erreichung des zweiten Ziels.
Sie steht damit in ihrer Bedeutung Figuren
wie Sergej Shoigu und Valerij Gerassimow in
nichts nach, im Gegenteil: für Putin ist
sie sogar noch wichtiger und gerade unersetzlich.
Nabiullina, die aus den marktwirtschaftlichen
und pro-demokratischen Kreisen Russlands stammt,
ist seit der Machtübernahme Putins eine seiner
engsten Vertrauten.
Zunächst war sie stellvertretende Ministerin
für wirtschaftliche Entwicklung und Handel.
Im Jahr 2007 wurde sie zur Ministerin des
ganzen Ressorts befördert und führes es
bis 2012.
Danach war sie Chefberaterin des Präsidenten
für wirtschaftliche Angelegenheiten und seit
2013 ist sie Leiterin der Zentralbank.
Diese Funktion über sie übrigens mit viel
mehr Autorität aus als die meisten ihrer
internationalen Kollegen: Denn Nabiullina
kontrolliert alles: Finanzen, Geldpolitik,
die Versicherungswirtschaft, Investmentfonds,
Banken, Staatsreserven und noch vieles mehr.
Im Finanzbereich ist sie die wahrscheinlich
wichtigste Persönlichkeit des ganzen Landes
und auch die russische Managerin mit dem höchsten
internationalen Ansehen.
Jahrelang war es ihr Ziel, den Rubel zu stabilisieren
und die Inflation zu bekämpfen.
Das tat sie mit eiserner Hand: Sie schloss
500 Banken, hob die Zinssätze weit über
die internationalen Sätze an und liberalisierte
ddie Landeswährung, um Russlands Integration
in die internationale Wirtschaft zu fördern.
Nun, was sie auch kräftig gefördert hat,
war die Verstaatlichung von fast 70 % des
russischen Bankensystems.
Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Tatsache ist, dass sich mit dem Angriff Russlands
auf die Ukraine auch die Nabiullinas Ziele
vollkommen verändert haben:
("Jahrelang hat die Zentralbank alles getan,
um Russland zu helfen, sich weiter in die
Weltwirtschaft zu integrieren.
Dann, am 24. Februar, musste sie plötzlich
das Gegenteil tun.
Andrej Mowtschan, ehemaliger russischer Bankmanager
und derzeit Finanzier in London)
Tatsache ist, dass Nabiullina ihrem Chef Putin
kurz nach dessen Angriffsbefehl ihren Rücktritt
"angeboten" hat.
Doch dieser lehnte "dankend" ab, verlängerte
ihr Engagament promt auf eine dritte Amtszeit
und verlieh ihr gleichzeitig weitere Vollmachten.
Sie ist jetzt auch noch für die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung Russlands verantwortlich.
Tja, war ein ganz schöner Bumerang, dieses
Rücktrittsgesuch, denn Nabiullina ist für
diese Herkulesaufgabe - manche sagen gar:
Himmelfahrskommando - wahrlich nicht zu beneiden.
Aber: diese geniale Frau hat selbst gestandene
Experten schon öfter überrascht.
Was hat sie also jetzt in Petto?
Nun, sperrt Eure Lauscher auf - jetzt geht's
ans Eingemachte!
Und Nabiullina wird kein Auge trocken lassen!
(DIE WIRTSCHAFTLICHE GEGENOFFENSIVE DES KREMLS)
Im Wesentlichen kann der russische Gegenangriff
auf die Sanktionen des Westens in zwei große
Aktionsbereiche von grundlegend unterschiedlichem
Charakter unterteilt werden: kurzfristige
Maßnahmen, um den sofortigen Abschurz abzufangen,
und eine langfristige Strategie, um die russische
Wirtschaft in den kommenden Monaten und sogar
Jahren widerstandsfähig zu machen, falls
die Strafmaßnahmen über einen längeren
Zeitraum andauern sollten - und davon ist
auszugehen.
In diesem Sinne hat die russische Regierung
seit 2014 als Erstes ihre Devisenreserven
aufgestockt, das Gewicht von Vermögenswerten
wie dem chinesischen Yuan und Gold erhöht
und möglicherweise einen großen Teil davon
sogar gut versteckt.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Die russische Zentralbank wird verdächtigt,
Dutzende von Milliarden Dollar auf zwielichtigen
Offshore-Konten versteckt zu haben, um internationalen
Sanktionen zu entgehen.
Die Rede ist von bis zu 80 Milliarden Dollar
an US-Staatsanleihen, die über sich ein komplexes
und intransparentenes Beteiligungs- und Firmenkonstrukt
auf den Kaimaninseln oder sogar in Belgien
versteckt sind, wo Euroclear, eine der größten
Vermögensverwaltungsgesellschaften der Welt,
ihren Sitz hat.
Es gibt auch Spekulationen, dass die russische
Zentralbank in der Lage war, rund 30 Milliarden
Dollar in ihren eigenen Tresoren anzuhäufen.
Der Punkt ist, dass diese versteckten Reserven
der russischen Regierung die Möglichkeit
bieten, die Sanktionen des Westens zu umgehen
und weiterhin auf den internationalen Märkten
zu agieren, ohne dass dies jemand offiziell
bemerkt.
Sie können zum Beispiel Russlands Auslandsschulden
zu einem Bruchteil ihres Wertes aufkaufen,
für wichtige Importe oder Investitionen bezahlen
und vor allem eines betreiben: massive Kurskosmetik.
Denn für die Machthaber im Kreml ist vor
allem der Kurs des Rubel ein ausgezeichnetes
Propaganda-Instrument, mit dem sie der eigenen
Bevölkerung sagen können, dass die Sanktionen
keine Wirkung haben – auch wenn die Wirtschaft
im Land eigentlich den Bach runter geht.
Also müssen sie den Kurs nach oben manipulieren,
koste es, was es wolle.
Und wie genau?
Nun, nachdem die internationalen Sanktionen
beschlossen wurden, stürzte der Rubel ab
wie eine Sukhoj nach der ungewollten Begegnung
mit einer Stinger.
Darauf reagierte die russische Zentralbank
mit einem Notfallpaket, das eine Zinserhöhung
auf zunächst sagenhafte 20, später noch
immer beachtliche 17% beinhaltete sowie die
Einführung strenger Kapitalkontrollen.
So wurden z.B. Abhebungen von Bankkonten in
Fremdwährung eingeschränkt, eine Steuer
und in einigen Fällen sogar ein vorübergehendes
Verbot für den Kauf von Fremdwährungen eingeführt,
und exportierende Unternehmen wurden verpflichtet,
80% ihrer ausländischen Einnahmen in Rubel
umzuwandeln.
Sie wurden auch verpflichtet, diese Auslandserlöse
nach Russland zu überweisen und im Lande
zu belassen.
Außerdem war es internationalen Investoren
untersagt, ihre Positionen an der Moskauer
Börse zu liquidieren oder Dividenden- oder
Zinszahlungen zu erhalten.
Am 9. März hat die russische Regierung außerdem
die Steuer auf den Kauf von Edelmetallen abgeschafft,
damit die Russen für ihre Ersparnisse lieber
inländisches Gold statt Dollar, Pfund oder
Euro kaufen.
Nach Angaben der Sberbank hat sich die Nachfrage
nach Gold in den ersten Märzwochen deswegen
vervierfacht.
Die dafür aufgebrachten Rubel landeten doch
nicht auf dem Devisenmarkt und konnten so
den Rubelkurs gegenüber Dollar und Euro nicht
drücken.
Aber das Ziel all dieser Maßnahmen war es,
die Kapitalflucht zu verhindern und den Rubelkurs
gegen über ausländischen Währungen durch
Kurskosmetik zu stützen – und zwar wie
gesagt um jeden Preis.
Wie hoch dieser Preis ist, werden wir gleich
sehen, denn aber auf den ersten Blick sieht
es ja so aus, als wäre es Frau Nabiullina
durchaus gelungen, den Fall des Rubel aufzuhalten,
sogar so sehr, dass sein Kurs am Devisenmarkt
heute höher steht als vor dem Krieg.
Und viele fragen sich nun: Wie kann das denn
sein?
Spiegelt die Kurserholung bei Rubel nicht
den Erfolg der russischen Wirtschaft im Kampf
gegen die Sanktionen wieder?
Nun, nicht im geringsten.
Das würde er tun, wenn es sich um einen freien
Markt handelt würde – doch davon kann keine
Rede mehr sein.
Der ist Rubel aufgrund der massiven durch
Russland betriebenen Interventionen, Verzerrungen
und Beschränkungen auf der internationalen
Bühne praktisch nutzlos geworden ist.
Denn überlegt mal eine Sekunde: Könnt Ihr
irgendeinen anderen Indikator außer des Rubelkurses
benennen, der darauf hinweisen würde, dass
die russische Wirtschaft jetzt die gleichen
oder gar bessere Aussichten hat als Mitte
Februar vor Beginn der Invasion?
Tja, diese krasse Anomalie zeigt, dass hier
irgendwas verdammt faul ist.
Der starke Rubel hat also ziemlich wenig mit
der russischen Wirtschaftskraft zu tun oder
damit, dass es den Russen in Zukunft besser
gehen wird.
Er beruht auf massiven Interventionen und
dem gleichzeitigen Zusammentreffen gleich
mehrerer Effekte, die zu einer Übertreibung
führen.
Vergesst bitte nicht, dass in Aufruhr geratene
Märkte oft von einem Extrem ins andere Schwanken,
da sich zunächst alle Teilnehmer zuerst auf
die eine Seite, also die Angebots- oder Nachfrageseite
stürzen und daraufhin wieder auf die andere.
Ein
Ich werde Euch gleich erklären, woraus diese
Effekte zur Zeit bestehen und wie sie sich
entwickeln werden.
Die russische Regierung kündigte an, für
ihre Rohstoffexporte nur noch Zahlungen in
Rubel zu akzeptieren und einige Abnehmer – wenn
auch nicht die großen – fügten sich diesem
Diktat auch.
Da der Rubel keine Währung ist, in der sonst
viel gehandelt wird und auch die Kapitalmarktkontrollen
in Russland dazu beigetragen haben, dass sich
der ohnehin enge Rubel-Markt auf der Angebotsseite
noch weiter verengte, führte diese erzwungene
Rubel-Nachfrage natürlich zu einem starken
Ungleichgewicht und Rubel-Mangel.
Dieser Sondereffekt wird sich nicht endlos
aufrecht erhalten lassen und deswegen führte
Putins Währungschefin Nabiullina einen weiteren
Kniff ein.
Die Zentralbank legte einen festen Preis für
Goldkäufe fest - 5.000 Rubel pro Gramm Gold.
Und die Frage ist, was das alles soll?
Nun, da es für Regierungen und große multinationale
Unternehmen wegen des knappen Angebots heutzutage
nicht so einfach ist, an Rubel zu kommen,
sollen sie ihre Käufe mit Gold bezahlen.
Dieses wird dann zu dem von der Zentralbank
festgelegten Preis in Rubel umgetauscht.
Im Gegensatz zu dem, was viele Medien berichten,
geht es nicht darum, zum Goldstandard zurückzukehren,
weil die russische Währung ohnehin nicht
konvertiebel sein wird.
Vielmehr geht es darum, den Rubelkurs noch
stärker zu polieren, die russischen Goldreserven
zu erhöhen und - ganz wichtig - das Petrodollar-System
anzugreifen, d.h. den Kauf von Erdöl mit
der Währung von Uncle Sam.
Dies gilt als einer der Eckpfeiler des Dollars
als Leitwährung, eine Stärke der USA, die
Länder wie China ebenfalls zu untergraben
versuchen.
Aber über diesen ambitionierten Plan, der
es wirklich in sich hat, werden wir bald ein
eigenes Video drehen.
Ihr dürft Euch schon freuen!
Trotzdem: Die Wette gegen den Dollar als Leitwährung
ist sehr riskant Wette.
Und nur wenn sie aufgeht, könnte Russland
wirklich profitieren.
Scheitert sie, wird Russland am Ende mit weniger
Devisen dastehen, mit denen es auf dem internationalen
Markt Waren kaufen könnte.
Waren, welche auch seiner Industrie dringend
benötigt werden.
Eine weitere Galgenfrist erhielt Putin ja
vorerst durch den enormen Anstieg der Rohstoffpreise.
Diese schossen aufgrund des Kriegs- und Sanktionsschocks
in die Höhe, obwohl es ja noch nicht zu wirklichen
Rohstoffengpässen in der Realwirtschaft gekommen
war.
Die Preissteigerungen beruhen hauptsächlich
auf spekulativen Wetten: Händler deckten
sich noch schnell mit Kontrakten auf zukünftige
Lieferungen ein – natürlich auf Pump – und
hoffen, diese dann mit Gewinn verkaufen zu
können.
Die Frage ist: wird ihre Spekulation aufgehen?
Denn die Zinserhöhungen der US-Notenbank
und das Lockdown-gebeutelte chinesische Wirtschaftswachstum
dürften mit hoher Wahrscheinlichheit eher
zu einem Konjunktureinbruch und damit einer
sinkenden Nachfrage nach Öl und anderen Rohstoffen
führen.
Die Preisexplosion, von der Moskau in den
vergangen zwei Monaten gut profitieren konnte,
ist also eher durch einen Effekt zu erklären,
der mit jenen Hamsterkäufen vergleichbar
ist, bei denen sich Leute mit Klopapier und
Speiseöl eindecken.
Und zwar viel mehr, als sie je brauchen werden.
Und das dicke Ende kommt eben, sobald die
Hamsterer wegbleiben bzw. ihre oft mit immer
teurer werdenden Krediten finanzierten Vorräte
wieder auf den Markt werfen müssen.
Dann brechen die Preise wieder ein und treffen
ein Russland, von dem sich sein Großkunde
Europa in der Zwischenzeit denn immer mehr
unabhängig gemacht haben wird.
Die Nachfrage wird dann noch weiter einbrechen
und mit ihr auch die Abnahmepreise – wobei
Russland zur Zeit sein Öl sowieso schon mit
starken Abschlägen gegenüber dem Weltmarktpreis
verkaufen muss, da es auf einen immer kleineren
Kreis von Käufern angewiesen ist und diese
ihre starke Position selbstverständlich ausnutzen.
Auf jeden Fall ist es die Kombination all
dieser Effekte, die sich nur auf einer Seite
auswirken – strenge Kapitalkontrollen, der
Einbruch der Importe nach Russland, der Umtauschzwang
zum Rubel beim Export und die gestiegenen
Rohstoffpreise, welche dazu geführt hat,
dass der Rubel im März und April so stark
gestiegen ist, dass er seinen Wert von vor
der Invasion sogar übertreffen konnte.
Das Problem daran: natürlich hat eine Währung,
auf der so viele Intervention lasten nicht
viel langfristigen Wert.
Und schon gar nicht verhindert diese oberflächliche
Kurskosmetik die restlichen Auswirkungen auf
die Volkswirtschaft des Landes.
Denkt daran, dass der Rubel der Sowjetunion
- der praktisch nichts wert war - einen offiziellen
Wechselkurs von 0,6 Rubel für einen Dollar
hatte.
Und die Sowjetunion war sicherlich nicht als
konkurrenzfähige Exportmacht bekannt.
Wenn man zum Beispiel aufhört, wichtige Komponenten
aus dem Ausland zu importieren, sinkt zwar
die Inlandsnachfrage nach Dollar, aber es
kann dann passieren, dass viele Unternehmen
im Land nicht mehr produzieren können und
sogar zusammenbrechen.
Natürlich führt eine solche Aufwertung der
Währung in Verbindung mit erdrückend hohen
Zinsen dazu, dass die produzierende Exportwirtschaft
des Landes jegliche Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
gegenüber dem Ausland verliert.
Kurzfristig wird also der Währungskurs aufpoliert,
langfristig erstickt Putin aber jenen Rest
wertschöpfenden verarbeitenden Gewerbes,
das es in Russland noch gab.
An eine Zukunft Russlands als global konkurrenzfähige,
diversifizierte und komplexe Exportnation
ist so überhaupt nicht mehr zu denken.
Alle Ressourcen der Wirtschaft, vom Kapital,
über Know-How bis hin zu Fachkräften und
Netzwerkeffekten, werden noch weiter voll
auf den Export von Bodenschätzen konzentriert,
wodurch Russland wieder allen Schwankungen
der Rohstoffpreise ausgesetzt sein wird.
Putin mimt mit diesem Wirtschaftskurs den
absoluten Anti-Erdogan.
Letzterer versucht ja, mit niedrigen Zinsen
und einer Schwachen türkischen Lira sein
Land zu einer industriellen Export-Macht zu
machen.
Nun ja: beide Extreme sind schädlich, denn
ihnen fehlt die Balance.
Sie führen die Wirtschaft eines Landes auf
einen einseitigen Kurs, wobei Erdogan gegenüber
Putin nun geradezu als Wirtschaftsgenie dasteht.
Wie dem auch sei: all diese Maßnahmen sind
nur für einen kurzen Zeitraum sinnvoll und
die Frage ist, was die russische Regierung
zu tun gedenkt, wenn sich die Situation über
Jahre hinzieht.
Man muss bedenken: die ersten beiden Monaten
der Sanktionen werden nicht repräsentativ
sein für die weitere Entwicklung.
Nun, Putin und Nabiullina haben da noch ein
paar weitere Kniffe parat.
Die russische Regierung scheint eine Strategie
vorzubereiten, um russische Aktien und Vermögenswerte
ausländischer Investoren aufzukaufen, natürlich
unter sehr hohen Abschlägen.
Ihre Idee ist, eine Gruppe von nationalen
Champions zu schaffen, große Unternehmen,
die praktisch alles übernehmen würden.
Im Grunde also, genau jene Strategie der wirtschaftlichen
Kontrolle weiter auszubauen, die Putins Regierung
in den letzten Jahren verfolgt hat.
Einige dieser Unternehmen sollen dann an Offshore-Märkten
notiert werden, wo sie Geld von Investoren
aus weniger „feindseligen“ Ländern aufnehmen
könnten.
Aus Ländern wie China oder den Petromonarchien
am Persischen Golf.
Ich frage mich allerdings, ob diese ihr Geld
wirklich in Unternehmen investieren werden,
die nach einem Muster gestrickt sind, dass
sich in der Vergangenheit als wenig leistungsfähig
und eher riskant erwiesen hat.
Eine Blaupause, nach der die jetzige Struktur
der russischen Rüstungsindustrie entworfen
wurde, welche gerade im Krieg nun bewiesen
hat, dass sie nichts auf die Reihe bekommt.
Wir haben darüber ja ausführlich im vorigen
Video gesprochen.
Gut, bleibt dem Kreml noch eine letzte Hoffnung,
seine Wirtschaft doch noch irgendwie aufpeppeln
zu können: wie bereits angekündigt wird
die Politik der Importsubstitution in voller
Breite ausgefahren und mit allen Kräften
unterstützt, indem z.B. einheimische Unternehmen
mit günstigen Krediten versorgt werden.
So sollen Firmen, die direkt Produkte herstellen,
die von den Sanktionen betroffen sind und
bisher aus dem Ausland importiert wurden,
nicht unter den horrenden Zinsen leiden müssen.
Das Problem: selbst wenn eine gewisse Substitution
gelingt, ist auf einem derart abgeschotteten
und schrumpfenden Markt mit nichts anderem
als ineffizienten Prozessen und minderwertiger
Qualität zu rechnen.
Aber dies wäre ja beileibe nichts Neues.
Als Teil dieser Strategie vertrauen Putin
und Nabiullina schließlich darauf, dass Länder
wie China und Indien am Ende die russische
Wirtschaft retten könnten und sie hoffen
sogar, dass die Sanktionen nicht ausgeweitet
oder bald zurückgefahren werden.
Immerhin weiß Moskau, dass die Welt nicht
bereit sein wird, auf ihre Rohstoffe zu verzichten
und US-Geheimdienste gehen bereits davon aus,
dass Putin auf nachlassende Entschlossenheit
des Westens setzt.
Das also ist Putins Plan: Sich von den westlichen
Volkswirtschaften abkapseln, seine Währung
mit Gold stärken, inländische Vermögenswerte
zurückgewinnen und darauf vertrauen, dass
China, Indien und andere ähnliche Länder
als ausreichender Rettungsanker fungieren
können, um den Sturm zu überstehen.
Natürlich könnte das leichter gesagt als
getan sein.
Im Moment sieht es überhaupt nicht danach
aus, dass Putins Plan Erfolg haben wird.
Russland ist zunehmend von der Weltwirtschaft
isoliert, und wie wir hier Euch auf VisualPolitik
vor kurzem in einem eigenen Video gezeigt
haben, wird ihm nicht einmal China unter die
Arme greifen.
(Die wirklichen Auswirkungen werden wir erst
spüren, wenn die Lieferketten und Produktionslinien
zusammenbrechen.
Das meiste, was in Russland produziert wird,
hängt von Komponenten aus dem Westen ab.
Und ohne diese Teile wird die Arbeit stillstehen.
In Automobilfabriken, bei Offshore-Bohrungen,
in der Luftfahrt und so weiter.
Natalia Zubarevich, russische Wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin
und Geografin)
Wir können auch nicht behaupten, wir wären
sonderlich überrascht.
Putins Pläne in Sachen Wirtschaft haben schon
lange nicht mehr sonderlich gut funktioniert.
In den letzten Jahren ist es mit der russischen
Wirtschaft immer weiter Abwärts gegangen.
Das russische Pro-Kopf-Einkommen ist von seinem
Höchststand von einst 16.000 US-Dollar binnen
zehn Jahren auf etwa 12.000 US-Dollar gesunken
– da lag es zumindest kurz vor der Invasion
der Ukraine .
Jetzt, angesichts der Sanktionen, deutet alles
darauf hin, dass es deutlich unter 10.000
USD fallen wird.
Das wäre ein Rückgang von fast 50 %, seitdem
Putin den initialen Reformkurs beiseite schoben
und anfing, seine eher nationalistische - und
despotische - Agenda Schritt für Schritt
umzusetzen.
Alles deutet darauf hin, dass die Russen für
die Aggression gegen die Ukraine teuer bezahlen
werden.
Einen großen Teil ihrer Devisenreserven haben
sie bereits verloren.
Hunderte von Milliarden Dollar, für welche
sie die ganzen Jahre zuvor Rohstoffe in alle
Welt geliefert haben sind nun eingefroren
und werden wohl für Reparationszahlungen
an die Ukraine verwandt.
Und dies wird erst der Anfang sein: die Jagd
nach russischem Vermögen hat eigentlich erst
begonnen.
Aber über diese Pläne und das spannende
Thema, wer den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine bezahlen
wird, werden wir bald ein eigenes Video herausbringen.
Vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo und – ganz
wichtig – das Glöckchen, um es ja nicht
zu verpassen.
Und jetzt kommen wie immer die Hausaufgaben:
Glaubt Ihr, dass die russische Wirtschaft
es schaffen wird, die internationalen Sanktionen
zu umgehen?
Kann der vom Westen entfesselte Wirtschaftskrieg
das Putin-Regime zu Fall bringen?
Werden die Sanktionen lange genug andauern?
Sollten die verbündeten Länder ihre Strafen
gegen Russland verschärfen?
Die Antworden sind wie immer bis Mitternacht
im Kommentarbereich abzugeben – eine Benotung
findet nicht statt, denn hier lernen wir für
uns selbst, nicht für eine billige Belohnung!
Ich hoffe also, dass Euch dieses Video, gefallen
hat, Ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habt.
Falls ja, gebt uns bitte ein Like, teilt es
mit Euren Freunden und vergesst nicht das
Abo mit Glöckchen, um keines unserer Videos
mehr zu verpassen.
Natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von Euch, mit der Ihr uns helft,
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen.
Den PayPal-Link dazu findet Ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video.
Macht’s gut und bis bald!